mais d'abord les étudiants en bts en
plein désarroi alors que les écoliers
ont fait leur rentrée ce matin eux
préparent leurs examens dans un climat
d'anciens d'anxiété à tel point qu'un
millier d'entre eux viennent de porter
plainte contre jean michel blanquer
après deux années marquées par les
confinements répétition ils réclament
l'annulation de leur épreuve au profit
d'un contrôle continu
c'est le cas de sarah et alexis deux
tourangeaux qu'ont rencontré hélène
chapelet et samuel que la sara et alexis
ont tous les deux 21 ans ils terminent
leur deuxième année de bts en management
commercial qu'ils effectuent en
alternance depuis 2019 pour alexis qui
travaille dans un magasin de bricolage
l'alternance a pu se poursuivre tout au
long de l'année ce qui n'est pas le cas
de sarah elle est vendeuse dans un
magasin de prêt-à-porter sa formation
sur le terrain s'est donc déroulée en
pointillés au gré des fermetures imposé
par le gouvernement
elles redoutent aujourd'hui de ne pas
avoir le niveau attendu pour son diplôme
très clairement j'aurais su comment ça
se passe et je pense que j'aurais pas
fait ni les ts oui déjà le fait d'être
distant ciel après il ya aussi bas on a
forcément eu moins d'expérience vu que
certaines entreprises ont été fermées
on a aussi moins d'expérience on a pu -
accomplir certaines missions qui doivent
être acquises dans notre bts pour des
prochaines entreprises qui vont se dire
bah voilà fait ce bts elle doit avoir
ses acquis bah pas forcément parce que
j'ai moins deux périodes d'entreprise
que prévu avec onze mois cumulés de
courant distant ciel sur leurs deux ans
de formation ses élèves tourangeau
appréhende les examens écrits qui vont
se dérouler à chinon à partir du 10 mai
prochain comme près de 80 mille autres
personnes
ils ont signé la pétition pour passer
leurs examens en contrôle continu
parce qu'ils ne vont pas réussir à finir
le programme mais aussi pour des raisons
sanitaires venir pour faire des écrits à
50 minutes de là on habite dans des
salles où on annoncera 30 40 voire même
plus ça dépend s'il y en a qui passent
leur bts dans des hangars en raison de
la crise sanitaire des chiffres qui
évolue constamment chaque jour cette
année cible les diplômes obtenus ces
deux dernières années en pleine crise
sanitaire qu'ils étaient validées par un
compte
le continu ou des épreuves en distance
yale auront-ils la même valeur que les
autres
c'est aussi l'une des craintes de ses
étudiants